you hosted turned out live but you did a
brilliant job thank you attacks you you
did a very I know you it was part of
your tour but this just amazing Chris
Farley song yes in the show I think that
that touched a lot of people people
really it's a terrific song it was such
a nice and appropriate place to do it
yeah that was an extra powerful feeling
up there singing about the man Farley
and you know we talked about how much he
meant to all of us but I was when I was
singing the song I looked out and I was
getting misty-eyed discuss all the nice
memories we had together in that in that
studio and then the cameraman were all a
lot of the same guys that a lot of the
crew was it's the same crew
you know from 25 years earlier that I
hung out with Farley and you look out
and see those guys and everybody look we
were all a little older there was
something just something very powerful
that night and it felt felt great
talking about Chris and it felt and his
and I spoke to John and his brother the
next day and he said that his mother you
know I called mrs. Farley the week up
and said I was going to do the the song
if she was okay with that it was nice
you asked for permission what I thought
was very sensitive okay to do this sure
yeah I didn't I didn't want to you know
I just wanted to make sure she was it
was something that she would want and
now she was very happy about it and then
John I told me that she was the head of
the beauty salon the next day everybody
was talking about Chris to her and that
was great yeah that was
[Applause]